[Musique]
notre conception de la démocratie ça
n'est pas une d une démocratie
multiculturelle eaux communautaires
parce qu'il n'ya qu'une seule nation
qu'un seul peuple n'y a pas un peuple
qui pourtant voile est un peuple qui
n'en portent pas il ya un amendement
déposé par le modem qui visait à
interdire le port du voile par les
assesseurs
on se souvient on va voir c'est possible
la photo de jordan bardella qui avait
mis le sujet sur le tapis
oser dire dans cet hémicycle
qu'aujourd'hui la france n'est pas multi
culturelle je ne sais pas dans quel pays
vous vivez mais clairement vous vivez
pas dans le même pays que moi et
j'espère que vous avez honte de ce que
vous dites
personnellement vous me donnez envie de
vomir il n'y a pas de problème de
prosélytisme dans les piscines comme
c'est le cadre à grenoble il n'y a pas
de problème dans les bureaux de vote
circulez ya rien à voir on change rien
on bouge rien et on se donne rendez vous
à la prochaine attaque terroriste
j'aimais presqu'envie de pas faire de
commentaire tellement je trouve ça
pathétique de la part d'eric ciotti
nous ne faisons pas une loi contre les
musulmans il est obsédé par la question
des musulmans dans notre pays nous ont
une loi contre toutes les formes de
radicalisation la comparer à des
assassins je suis scandalisée temps
d'analyser pour cette dame ou devrais je
veux rendre hommage
vingt six élèves quels que soient ceux
qui l'ont rocade sur la tête pour venir
tenir les bureaux de vote peut-être
qu'avec plus de dames comme elle est
moins de gens comme vous la démocratie
s'en porterait mieux
réaction de marlène schiappa face à eric
ciotti est profondément scandaleuses
voilà je trouve que encore une fois elle
elle fait de la politique mais du coup
elle se rend complice de ce genre
d'attitude et je suis candidat
présidentiel effectivement avec cette
primaire écolo écologistes en septembre
je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle parce que j'aime la
france sa diversité ses terroirs son
modèle social et républicain et je veux
la servir engagé à soutenir celui ou
celle qui sortira victorieux des
primaires si c'est pas vous je ne suis
pas manuel valls mois donc effectivement
quand je suis engagé quelque part je
suis loyal 1 c'est ce qu'ils disent je
joue mais si je gagne j'irai jouer
ailleurs non nous faisons partie la
politique est un exercice éminemment
collectif en angleterre d'avoir à faire
avec les écologistes aujourd'hui
politiquement parlant
moi je défends l'écologie n'est pas à
travers un parti non plus plus à travers
un parti parce que je pense encore une
fois qu'il faut s'émanciper de ça ça
veut pas dire que heureusement que les
écologistes sont là d'ailleurs si on les
avait écoutés depuis longtemps on en
serait on n'en serait pas là
mais ce sujet est trop grave trop
complexe pour simplement être traités
par une seule formation on peut pas
faire un pari sur le résultat des
élections présidentielles maison
d'édition albin michel a fait son
annonce dans un communiqué elle ne
publiera pas le prochain livre d'eric
zemmour prévue pour la rentrée en raison
de ses ambitions politiques
nous avons eu un échange très franc avec
eric zemmour qui m'a récemment confirmé
son intention de s'engager dans la
présidentielle et de faire de son
prochain livre un élément clé de sa
candidature en sus il ya quelqu'un
derrière
non je prends la décision d'alain michel
dans notre pays des éditeurs sont plutôt
des femmes les hommes libres et un
éditeur peut décider ou pas d'éditer
quelqu'un qui est aujourd'hui un homme
politique
eric zemmour est un homme politique
accessoirement multi condamné et par
solidarité philippe de villiers
quitte à son tour albin michel pour
dénoncer ce qu'ils appellent la censure
d'eric zemmour pour l'édition de son
prochain livre eric zemmour vient de
faire un communiqué à la fp il dit qu'il
n'a jamais dit à son éditeur albin
michel et qu'il était candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
il dément formellement ce qu'a dit
rigolard ailleurs albin michel et très
inélégant dire il nous a dit qu'il
serait candidat comme si on fait du
dévoile end annonce de candidature à sa
place pour la deuxième année consécutive
vous ne verrez pas ces images à lille en
septembre hilaire les lillois ont appris
l'annulation de la grande braderie
donc c'est effectivement toujours un
crève coeur bat pour moi pour vous tous
j'ai imaginé pour tous les habitués de
la braderie j'étais contre l'obligation
et il me semble que maintenant on est on
a atteint le niveau ou en tout cas on
doit envisager une obligation au niveau
des soignants